harry potter the boy who lived whatever
you call him harry's iconic journey
starts off
not too great as he's living with the
worst family you could possibly imagine
his life is about to drastically change
forever though when hogwarts and hagrid
come calling you're a wizard harry the
gentle giant introduces harry to the
magical world of wizardry where harry
gets his wand owl hedwig
and meets the definitely not evil
professor quarrel he meets the rest of
the golden trio and makes sure they know
he's the main character
by buying the entire trolley of candy
we'll take the lot
things are about to get hectic for harry
and friends which will happen when you
leave children largely unsupervised in a
giant magic castle
harry gets placed in the gryffindor
household catches the golden snitch in
his mouth
fights a troll plays giant wizard's
chest and finds himself threatened by
professor quarle who is
gasp the evil voldemort but that's no
problem for harry
evil is defeated 170 points to
gryffindor and the year ends with
everyone happy
except for slytherin